est-ce que 2020 sera une année charnière
et à mon avis non c'est pas 2020 qu'il
faut retenir je pense que l'année qui a
amorcé le changement c'est 2008 en
réalité c'est la grande crise financière
de 2008 2009 qui a commencé à faire
prendre conscience en asie et en chine
en particulier qu'il y avait des grosses
faiblesses des grosses vulnérabilité du
côté occidental et que la chine avait sa
carte à jouer je pense que c'est à ce
moment là que lol
le basculement a commencé véritablement
à ceux à se faire alors 2020 vient
confirmer ce basculement
mais à mon avis il n'y a rien de
vraiment très totalement nouveau
bourreau en réalité avec avec la crise
du coc vider la bannière dont la chine a
géré cette crise du covin bon pour
autant je ne pense pas qu'on s'achemine
vers un monde qui sera dominé par l'asie
comme vous le disiez parce que à nouveau
comme ça a été dit précédemment
l'asie ça ne veut pas dire grand chose
l'asie est multiple l'asie est très
diverse et la chine est un élément mais
un élément qui n'est pas nécessairement
l'élément dominant est que tout le monde
va suivre en asie il y à de grosses
tensions en asie
le comportement de la chine en 2020 n'a
fait qu'attiser aussi ces tensions au
sein de ce continent asiatique et donc
je ne vois pas une asie 13 unis qu'ils
s'opposeraient à l'occident si tenté
d'ailleurs que l'occident et lui-même
étaient unis complètement ces derniers
temps et donc voilà j'aurai aussi une
réponse un peu mesuré
il ya un changement il ya un basculement
il était amorcée depuis longtemps mais
pour autant on ne va pas je pense vers
le monde qui sera exclusivement
asiatiques et avec l'occident qui
étaient à la traîne
[Musique]